like an apocalypse a phenomenon around
the globe impacting pretty much everyone
everywhere at the same time the great
lockdown robbed us of our freedoms and
our daily lives shops restaurants
playgrounds schools or closed personal
contact was prohibited millions of
people were locked in their homes for
weeks on end some say it came at a huge
economic cost but saved millions of
lives others suggest that burden was so
great it actually cost lives there is no
glory in prevention Germany's chief
neurologist Cassandra Austin on the
steps taken to slow the spread of the
corona virus
medical experts weren't popular in some
places even though they may have saved
millions of lives that's the conclusion
of a new study in the journal Nature in
a moment we'll ask an expert how
effective quarantine was first let's run
the numbers the lockdown saved lives
that's the finding from Imperial College
London researchers there created a model
of what would have happened if nothing
had been done to contain the pandemic no
quarantine no shutdown of public life
they examined several European countries
they didn't look at the infection rate
though but the number of deaths which
the researchers said was the key measure
of effectiveness
that's because deaths are reported in
roughly the same way across Europe
infection numbers on the other hand are
less certain
the reporting systems vary and follow
different standards death numbers are
much clearer
they are tallied quickly everywhere
Britain can be compared easily with two
European neighbours Italy and Germany
there are countries with similar sizes
and structures how many people would
have died if the coronavirus had been
left to run its course
the numbers the researchers came up with
are startling six hundred seventy
thousand people would have died in the
UK in Germany that would have been five
hundred and seventy thousand
in Italy 500,000 the experts emphasize
that these are hypothetical values based
on mathematical models in the real world
people would have taken steps to protect
themselves no matter what the government
did but it shows that the lockdowns and
school closings had an effect and are
still having one without them many more
people would have died here's how things
have turned out as of last week in
Britain nearly 43,000 patients had died
of kovat 19 in Italy that was nearly
35,000 but in Germany there were just
under 9,000 dead the Imperial College
scientists say the British death toll
could have been much lower if steps had
been taken earlier every three to four
days
before lockdown interventions were
introduced so had we introduced measures
that we can do reduce a final death toll
by lose the heart so prevention is
crucial but early intervention may be
the key to saving lives
Tapia's Court is an epidemiologist and
director of the Institute of Public
Health at the Chateau T hospital here in
Berlin thank you very much for being on
the show again first of all when we look
at those numbers Britain Germany Italy
all very different scenarios there but
what do these numbers actually mean
first of all one has to understand that
the underlying population is different
so the population size so just looking
at the absolute numbers is difficult
because the the size of the population
in these countries are different then
obviously also the classification is
different so what do you call a patient
and I think of 819 what is the test
strategy and so comparing countries is
not as easy but the broad picture is
very obviously a
thus whether she is different and the
reaction and possibilities of the
healthcare system also differed which
may have explained some of these
differences what about when it comes to
Sweden a relatively small country a
sweeping lockdown didn't happen but they
had a higher number of deaths yes they
had a higher number of deaths relative
to the population size which may
indicate that the strategy may not be
optimal for Sweden but the officials
there and the scientists are watching
the situation very carefully and trying
to react according to the Swedish system
what do you think is coming our way as a
second lockdown is that conceivable it's
certainly conceivable right now the
numbers are rising in several countries
dramatically rising and several states
for example in the United States after
lockdown have opened up and and now I
see a dramatic rise and a substantial
burden for the healthcare system so I
think at least on the local level a
second lockdown is very likely until we
have a medication or a vaccine available
to treat cope with 19 what's that going
to mean though if a second look it means
it means that well first of all commit
19 happened locally in regions so not in
a country as a whole but it's always in
regions so at the lockdown that we had
during the first wave so-called first
wave affected mostly countries so our
state levels and so hopefully by now we
have measures in place that will allow
us to if necessary have lockdowns on a
more regional more smaller level so just
a city or like a village or like a very
small region rather than a state or a
country that's what I mean when I say we
hopefully have measures in place that
will allow us to react more flexible but
does it mean opening up closing down
over and over I mean can't that go on
forever or at some stage we're going to
have to come to terms with the reality
of of living with this disease
absolutely and the reality is that the
virus is still there and we're trying to
open up and the the issue is of course
we have some of the weather's noise
people go outside and they forget that a
virus is there so wearing masks
particularly if you go inside a very
mass is very important keeping the
distance then testing tracing people
isolating people who have been tested
positive it's very important and not all
countries are ready to actually conduct
these measures that's why the ultimate
solution then is unfortunately then a
lockdown you heard it from Tobias court
epidemiologist and director of the
Institute of Public Health at the shotty
here in Berlin thank you and let's check
in with our science correspondent Derek
Williams he's been busy researching the
answers to your questions on all things
corona related can someone who has been
infected and cured of kovat 19 be
reinfected I've answered this a couple
of times over the months but it's one of
those topics that means regular updates
especially in light of a couple of
recently published studies showing that
antibody levels are dropping off in a
pretty big way in a lot of people who
had COBIT 19 within three months of
their infection especially in those who
were asymptomatic now antibody levels it
has to be said aren't the only factor to
play a role in long term immune response
but but still this isn't positive news
when it comes to our hopes that getting
kovat 19 will stop you from getting it
again for at least a year or two that
said over six months into the pandemic
there's still no clear-cut evidence of
someone being infected again after
having already been through the disease
once how likely is the transmission of
influenza on airline flights
to find out how dangerous flying could
be potentially in the in the kovat
nineteen era it's a good idea to look
back at research in planes that we've
done in the past on the spread of
viruses like influenza
now the w-h-o says transmission of
infectious pathogens happens mostly
between people seated in the same area
on the plane so the risk is highest
within those few rows but but it
concludes that the risk is otherwise no
higher than it is on on a train or a bus
or or in a theater but I tracked down a
meta-study from 2016 and one of the
interesting things it had to say was
that research on the topic really
doesn't always agree and that our data
is not really that robust so to be
truthful it looks like we still don't
know really exactly how likely pathogen
transmission is on a plane just that it
grows more likely the closer you sit to
the infected person what lessons are
being learned to prevent the next
pandemic how are they being compiled and
disseminated I think there are many
lessons to be learned or maybe re
learned from this pandemic one is that
we need to be more prepared for for when
this happens again and and sooner or
later we know it will another is that
that transparency and acting fast
especially in the early stages of a
novel pathogen outbreak is absolutely
vital unfortunately for us humans
lessons learned often don't necessarily
translate into into lessons retained
when it comes to compiling and
disseminating learned lessons it seems
to me that that the World Health
Organization would be a natural
repository but at the same time the
mistakes the w-h-o is made in the course
of this current pandemic have revealed
some some pretty deep flaws in my
opinion
the organization needs reforms that not
only give it a clearer mandate but that
also give it the means to carry that
mandate out because next time we really
have to do a better job at coordinating
an international response
[Music]